you
you
all right welcome everybody we have a
Sunday night's stream I've been doing
these lately they seem to do pretty well
and I just kind of go over what I'm
going to be talking about on the show at
least on the Monday show sometimes later
in the week and today I actually I need
to go through all the voicemails that
came in over the weekend also maybe you
guys can help me pick which ones will
make it onto the show you I don't I'm
sort of scared to reveal how small the
percentage of useable voicemails is most
of them are completely unusable
sometimes people will call in 6 7 8 9
times in a row using the full three
minutes that it's allowed and it's a
disaster so there's a LAN for I don't
know if it's to my advantage and maybe
it'll be useful for leaving better
voicemails in the future but maybe there
is some way in which this will be
embarrassing I don't know and I've got a
bunch of different videos and things to
show you so let me get my headphones on
here and of course the requisite windows
sounds always always a necessity there
hope everybody's been having a good good
weekend we are live on Twitch and on
YouTube over on YouTube I am always glad
to take questions via super chat and you
can send those in and they will pop up
and it will be it will really be an
amazing thing as my prediction over on
Twitch makes sure to include any
questions or comments with your twitch
Prime subscriptions or whatever people
asking why live is in the title that's
for YouTube that's for YouTube just so
that it's clear over there that that we
are actually live so one of the
interesting things that's going on oh
and and I may take phone calls if we get
15 new members on the website I we may
take phone calls that's always available
always on the table up to you not
mandatory completely and totally up to
you okay let's get right into it
Oh first of all a piece of content came
from let me see where it is so last
stream we were listening to voicemails
and we came across what we dubbed
hillbilly voicemail and we were able to
turn that into a video with subtitles
and it's pretty funny
you guys were sort of the source of this
because this this came up while while I
was streaming last time take a listen to
what uh what we got out of it yeah hey
David Pakman you know you think that
it's a damn bad living in the United
States what crumbs gone maybe you oughta
leave you sucker loan pick up your [ __ ]
move your ass to Iran so you can kiss
their asses what do you think of that
[ __ ]
get her done buddy bye yeah anyway so
nearly 50,000 views just on Twitter and
then I posted it to our YouTube page I
think it probably got another similar
number of views there I posted it to my
Instagram it got another 10,000 just a
random little voicemail that ended up
getting you know probably a hundred
thousand views across all of the
different platforms so very exciting
stuff and we will get to voicemails very
very soon
Christopher hatch says via super chet do
you ever listen to Boston's WBZ 10:30
Dan Rhea I have no idea who that is
I have not listened to broadcast radio
for years I couldn't tell you who's
doing what or anything like it so no
Christopher right I have not listened to
that I basically listen to music on
Sirius XM and that is it thanks to our
Zim coy for subscribing with twitch
prime over on Twitch alright so we've
got really interesting stuff going on
where corporate media and Trump are both
panicking because Bernie Sanders whose
name was misspelled as Bernie sander
during a recent MSNBC segment is polling
first in the Des Moines Register Iowa
poll now this is what matters about this
okay polls go up polls go down national
polls state polls things come and go
we're now three weeks from the Iowa
caucuses and at this point in time
historically the important poll the gold
standard pole the pole we look at to say
what is the next step in how is that
step looking
it's the Des Moines Register Iowa poll
during January this is what you look at
it's a very important poll and in that
poll
Bernie Sanders is now winning he is at
20% Elizabeth Warren is at 17% Pete boot
edge edge is at 16% Joe Biden is at 15
as you see
tulsi very very low I know that upsets a
lot of people in the audience Amy
Klobuchar are at 6 that upsets a lot of
people in the audience as well for how
high it is you know whatever these are
the numbers and all of a sudden Trump's
tweeting about Bernie and he seems very
scared and we'll get to that in a second
and oh people are texting me which I
apologize for there we go and we're
gonna get the Trump in a second but
MSNBC CNN everybody's panicking about
how do we couch this to not make it seem
like the establishment will potentially
lose so let's start with this segment
from MSNBC where you will see that they
immediately bring on an expert who at
first sort of seems to say that maybe
you can't trust the poll but then he
knows this is the poll this is the gold
standard poll that we look at at this
point every election and so then he says
well I just think that it's going to
change so they're just figuring out how
can we discredit at least the likelihood
of this poll telling us who's going to
win Iowa let's take a look I am
perplexed by this poll for two reasons
first either the people of Iowa or
schizophrenic or they just aren't
convinced they remain skeptical yeah I
mean you don't I don't think the people
of Iowa are schizophrenic although they
didn't have to horrifying
GOP senators as their senators but
that's December conversation for a
separate day this poll is not an outlier
this is in fact as Fernan said the gold
standard this is it when it came out
last night at 7 o'clock or whatever time
it came out eastern time I looked at it
went no way in hell is this right but it
has to be right because it's Des Moines
right yeah Des Moines Register and see
it in and so I mean I just don't see
this I think a lot can change between
now and the day of those caucuses and I
done these numbers they tell me
something at 30,000 feet they tell me
nothing on the ground in Des Moines or
Dubuque or anywhere else that okay now
why it matters what the numbers are in
Des Moines or Dubuque in the context of
a primary that is happening statewide
okay to some degree it matters because
you've got to get to that 15 percent
threshold in any
precinct I believe I'm trying to use
caucus language instead of primary
language I think they're still called
precincts okay so here is where they
first start saying well okay I mean I
guess we can't really discredit it but
I'll kind of play coy with that and then
I'll say it could change on CNN they're
just taking a totally different approach
let me see if I can zoom this out for us
on CNN they're using the terminology no
clear leader now this is interesting not
because so what's the justification for
no clear leader the the no clear leader
justification is you have five points
separating four candidates with a margin
of error of almost four points okay but
were they saying that when it was Biden
in the lead were they saying that when
it was Pete booed edge edge in the lead
and in fact I can pull up let me pull up
the Iowa polling let's just look at it
all together here if we go back and look
at Iowa you will see that you had a long
period of time let's zoom out a little
bit you had this long period of time
where it was Biden just crushing and I
can assure you even here like where
Biden was only up by four or here where
Biden was down to one by one to Warren
they were not at that point saying
anything other than establishment
centric things oh and I kind of zoomed
it in weirdly and I apologize for that
when Pete Buddha judge took over and as
you can see there was one point here
where he tied and then he took a few
point lead up to six so five and a half
and then it started going down the
narrative only becomes we have no clue
what's going on when Bernie Sanders is
in the lead so it's like yeah listen
it's true that this is within the margin
of error but the focus on the margin of
error and it's not really clear who's
winning it's an it's an issue when it's
Bernie now does this mean that Bernie is
going to win no it doesn't does this
mean Iowa is the be-all end-all of the
of the primary no in fact I would argue
and I will talk about this on tomorrow's
program I think Iowa will matter less in
this primary maybe then it ever has
because the DNC in order to take
importance away from Iowa and New
Hampshire
has scheduled the Nevada and South
Carolina primaries very soon after Iowa
and New Hampshire and then within just a
month you've got the I believe it's
March is it March 6 that's a Tuesday
where you have a whole bunch of
elections March no March 3rd is it yeah
you I don't I don't have the calendar in
front of me so it's playing it's always
playing with the narrative so my advice
is anytime you see a headline about a
poll ignore the headline just go and
look and see what the poll says and what
the poll says here and what the trend
line is is that Bernie Sanders after
nearly tying Joe Biden way back in March
I mean that's 10 months ago and then
after dropping all the way down to 12%
has basically the blue line been just
climbing climbing climbing you don't
have to like Bernie or dislike Bernie
simply to recognize that this type of
coverage is dishonest coverage its
establishment centric coverage you don't
have to think that Bernie's gonna pass
Medicare for all you might think he will
you might think he won't this coverage
we have to be extremely skeptical of
because it is so establishment that
eccentric Daniel Krieger says via super
chat I love watching these pundits cry
yeah it's not so much that they're
crying it's all they're just trying to
craft they're just trying to craft
narrative is basically the the point of
what they're doing let me say thanks to
Charles Wendell burger Charles Wender
Wendell burger is the first member a new
member of the evening and as you can see
we are starting to work our way across
hopefully to 15 members at which point
the phone lines will open over on Twitch
thanks to Z Zack for subscribing with
twitch prime asking do you think the
narrative about Bernie have us having a
ceiling makes any sense it makes as much
sense as any other narrative I mean so
there's a couple ways you can look at
that you could say in order to figure
out someone's narrative you've got to
figure out how much support do they have
in the polls and then add in their
second choice support and then maybe add
in their third choice support not every
poll does third choice and that might
give you a sense of the ceiling but that
doesn't really tell you very much about
what can happen nationally
and it's ultimately going to come down
that whatever there we identify as a
candidate's ceiling or floor once you're
up against Trump and it's a national
race and who knows if Trump's getting
tried in the Senate by the way I haven't
paid any attention to anything this
weekend have they set a date for the
Senate trial or is that still not
happening I don't know maybe somebody
can tell me I will be caught up by
tomorrow all bets are off it's going to
come down to a few key States more than
likely the Democratic candidate is going
to win the popular vote in November and
Trump may win or may not win electoral I
consider this an invitation by the way
to re-up your twitch Prime subscription
let's do a couple other Super chats here
let's see are you voting for Warren or
Bernie oh I've already said I'm not
there's no point in me saying now who
I'm going to vote for I'm not going to
unnecessarily divide my audience there
will be people no matter what I say
people in my audience will say I'm doing
the wrong thing or now this has become a
channel that is shilling for one
candidate or the other I've been making
every effort to make it clear that I'm a
progressive I'm voting for a progressive
in the primary and in the fall well in
the fall there may not be a progressive
on the candidate but there's no point to
unnecessarily dividing my audience next
one can I borrow four dollars and 20
cents and they send me four dollars and
20 cents well now that YouTube takes its
cut I don't have the 420 to give you
unfortunately okay very good
let's continue I have other things to go
oh oh okay so then bernie is now being
attacked by Donald Trump and Donald
Trump appearing a few hours ago saying
Wow crazy Bernie Sanders is surging in
the polls looking very good against his
opponents in the do-nothing Party so
what does this all mean stay tuned I
think Trump is not particularly thrilled
about the idea of running against Bernie
whether Trump really thinks Bernie's
ideas are crazy or not and they're not I
mean Bernie's ideas are established
government policy in you know more than
half a dozen countries in Europe there's
nothing crazy about Bernie's ideas I
don't think that Trump is particularly
excited to run
Burnie and again think about all the
time and effort that Donald Trump has
put into planning to run against Joe
Biden I mean as far as we know he didn't
go and threaten to withhold aid to other
countries to get him to find dirt on
Bernie right it was to find dirt on
Biden and so I don't I don't know that
Donald Trump will will even really know
how to run against Bernie and remember
Donald we know what Donald Trump's two
defenses against or attacks on Bernie
are going to be they are going to be
Bernie's crazy Bernie wants just free
things for everybody
Bernie's a socialist this will never be
a socialist country although socialist
is a term that is seen less negatively
now in the United States than it has
been in a very very long time I don't
know how much Trump has a sense of how
to run against Bernie Sanders whereas
Trump knows how to run run against Joe
Biden he's gonna go after burries MA
he's going to go after corruption he's
going to go after failures of Biden
during the Obama administration with Joe
Biden has not really addressed very well
when Joe Biden has been asked about well
under the Obama administration you guys
failed to do this you guys failed to do
that and Biden basically I said I wasn't
the president I was the vice president
but of course he's also very quick to
take credit for successes under the
Obama administration so I think that
Trump knows how to run against Biden way
more it's way clearer than how to run
against Bernie Sanders that that's my
sense and I'm glad to hear from folks
thanks to a Turnus for subscribing with
twitch prime thanks to jolla Hippo for
subscribing for three months in a row
with twitch prime also want to say
thanks to Carl's ipil for signing up at
join pakman.com and dave hunt for
signing up at join pakman.com very much
appreciate that I will continue taking
questions and comments bye super chat on
YouTube and via the messages you can
attach to your twitch Prime subscription
over on Twitch okay let's go next here's
a very interesting interview I'm hoping
to get to this tomorrow on the broadcast
show but I I'm a not Donald Trump was
recently interviewed by Laura Ingraham
and to her credit Laura Angra hem did
sort of try to keep Trump accountable on
some things but you know every time
something like this happens like when
you've got I don't know when tucker
carlson is against something that trumps
doing but for the wrong reasons it's
important to understand how that can the
echo chamber of the Fox News viewer but
usually the disagreement is based in a
policy that we also find despicable as
people of the left and and that is
clearly the case here with Laura
Ingraham so we're gonna get to this
momentarily but first I do want to
answer this is this is actually a super
chat that it's something that I'm going
to be talking about tomorrow Andrew
Dwyer says could Trump possibly pull off
not debating Democratic candidate in
general he recently said that he would
not debate let's actually pull that up I
have these the tweets in my notes I
think that that is a real possibility
and if you're of the mindset that Donald
Trump is simply scared to debate if
you're of the mindset that Donald
Trump's cognitive decline may make him
look very bad during debates back on
December 16th I wasn't gonna do this
today I was gonna save it for tomorrow
but let's do it Donald Trump tweeted
what may be a signal that he is at least
opening the door to not debating where
he said I look very much forward to
debating whoever the lucky person is who
stumbles across the finish line and the
little watched do-nothing Democrat
debates my record is so good on the
economy and all else including debating
his record on debating he looked like an
idiot in three debates against Hillary
and otherwise has never debated that
perhaps I would consider more than three
debates the problem is that the
so-called Commission on Presidential
Debates is stacked with Trump haters and
never Trump errs three years ago they
were forced to publicly apologize for
modulating my microphone in the first
debate against crooked Hillary as
president as president the debates are
up to me and there are many options
including doing them directly and
avoiding the nasty politics of the
biased capital C Commission I will make
a decision at an appropriate time but in
the meantime the Commission on
Presidential Debates
is not authorized to speak for me or
Republicans so you know that this is
Trump
potentially signaling that he is not
going to debate at all and and leaving
the the door open to do it for any
number of reasons okay over on Twitch
the hype train is starting this is a fun
we got to hype train level two last time
this is a new thing I guess where if
bits and subs come in there's a hype
train and we're at 81% of level one
right now and I guess then we could get
to level two and then potentially to
level three we've never been to level
three during one of my streams Sam cedar
thanks for Sant to Sam cedar for
cheering 300 bits with the message
you're very attractive oh thanks Sam
I'll text you after the show I
appreciate it
also k2 squared - cheered one bit okay
let's get into this interview actually
let me just do a couple of other super
chats while they're here and gray can I
take you on a date so we can eat matzo
balls you know I don't I don't eat matzo
balls just loose a loose matzo ball is
not something I've ever eaten but you
know matzo ball soup is great they've
got a great matzo ball soup at a place
called Mama's Inn in Cambridge they've
got a great matzo ball soup at another
place called our father's up in I guess
it's technically in Brighton but you
will not find me eating a loose matzo
ball soup okay we reached level two of
the hype train on Twitch and we have
four minutes and 40 seconds to
potentially reach level three we've
never ly reached level three so to the
extent that it's a completely arbitrary
and meaningless thing let's do it let's
get right into this interview now so
again the context here is Laura Ingraham
being tough with Trump holding Trump
accountable but she's almost as loony as
he is let's take a look
146,000 jobs unemployment historically
low at 3.5% but we do have a little bit
of a stall out on wage growth which we
ran on and we've seen some 2.9 percent
last year
over the last month but we don't have a
tight labor market if we had a tight
labor market would be seeing real
increases in wages I hear that your team
is planning on advocating more foreign
workers coming in for some of these
high-tech companies very so understand
let's see it so here's the setup it's
like when tucker carlson last week said
posit by the way when tucker carlson
last week said i don't want that we was
stupid to kill soleimani iran's not the
biggest threat let's not do it we've got
problems to deal with here one of the
problems Tucker wants to deal with is
too many Brown people making the country
dirtier okay so while we agree with the
policy conclusion we don't agree with
the reasoning behind it similarly here
Laura Ingraham is saying you know we we
we I've heard you're gonna do something
to maybe do something helpful for the
economy but you're bringing in more
foreigners we don't want that because
she is one of these xenophobes sort of
nationalist type so let's continue
here's the problem I'm demanding that
Japan and all these companies the
countries that have these massive we
have a trade deficits like nobody's ever
seen before I say you gotta open up I
call Prime Minister Robby's a friend of
my sessions and you got to open up more
plants in the United States and they
tell me we want to do what we want to do
if they start open they can't get labor
we need help
otherwise we could just say don't labor
wages would be going up not in the
high-tech industry we're seeing a flat
towing and wait a three percent in the
wind up 2.9 percent in the last two
years wages have gone up more than they
have in 25 years but for Google why
reward Google Google's working against
you I don't want to reward those low
skilled workers not a fan
great companies okay you didn't run on
bringing more foreign workers and
videophone workers we have to allow
smart people to stay in our country
you graduated number one in your class
at Harvard you graduate from you ran on
people training their foreign
replacements that you ran against that
you've you've Americans it's humiliating
for an American worker work for a
company for 30 years now it's told you
got to train your foreign replacement is
gonna live in Korea that's different
that's I would never do that but we do
need workers in our country and I do
want an immigration policy nobody's been
better on immigration than me by the way
we won the funding for the wall and the
Walsman oh now he just goes into lies
that now everything he says from here on
out is completely fulfilled anyway
because I was taking it out of the
military everything else and now it's
easier
we need people I got Foxconn to go into
Wisconsin they have to get people this
they spent a fortune they built the most
incredible plants I've ever seen in
Wisconsin Foxconn graduates of colleges
and we do but we don't have enough of
them we're not we don't have enough of
them and we have to be competitive with
the rest of the world too if the
companies want to hire these people and
hire people they can hire for the
cheapest amount because I'm talking
about brainpower they want to hire smart
people and those people are thrown out
of the country I can't do this
I ran on America first if we tell smart
people to get the hell out there's a
never ending side on the part of
corporate America to bring in as much
cheap labor as possible to drive down I
have so many companies coming into this
country you're not gonna have to worry
about it it's always gonna be a shortage
if somebody smart sitting in this
position now we have so many companies
coming in from Japan Japan's doing many
car companies
China now is gonna start behind a lot of
things you know they haven't been doing
it too much we have so many companies
wanting to come in and they don't have
the labor but coming in okay so let so
from a macroeconomic perspective of
course laura ingraham is right if you
just if you flood the labor market with
people willing to work for less they're
going to work for less that's why you
need a minimum wage and of course the
biggest beneficiaries of undocumented
immigrant labor are of course the
corporations that don't that that that
rarely if ever are actually held
accountable for the crime that they are
committing and hiring undocumented
immigrants and instead we make the focus
about people who are just coming here
trying to get get themselves a better
life but so so anyway the point here is
laura Ingram's politics basically are
disgusting and terrible but she's
figured out a way to appear to be
holding Trump accountable that has some
semblance of economic sense much like
when target Carlson held Trump
accountable and we know that ultimately
his politics and his motives are ones
that we completely disagree with we
reached level three of the hype train on
Twitch for the first time thanks to the
let's see who do I need to thank I need
to thank smite bright for the bits as
well as glurg a bull gash manic for
subscribing with twitch prime CG bang
for subscribing with twitch prime saying
keep up the great work
breezy and Sam cedar sent some twit some
bits breezy sent some more bits T man 20
rocks signed up and then we got bits
from MF Kool Aid and breezy and k2
squared so we have three minutes to make
it to level four and that we have we
have certainly never done completing
level 3 requires combined support events
totaling five tier one subs or 2100 bits
and we just did it thanks to smite Brite
giving out five Tier one community subs
very exciting so I think now we are at
hype train level something else alright
let me get to some of the other super
chats that have been coming in over on
YouTube and then I have many more things
to talk to you guys about Daniel Krieger
says I love you but
some balls and endorsed Bernie oh jeez
Sean guys says some YouTube commentators
are saying that Warren should drop out
to support Bernie since Bernie is first
for Warren supporters second choice do
you agree let's see if those are the
numbers let's take a look morning
consult has some good numbers on that so
let's take a look at those morning
consult who's leading let's see second
choice here we go okay so Sanders
supporters have as their top second
choice Warren and Warren supporters have
as their top second choice Bernie
so in this poll Sanders has 23 and then
33% of Warren's supporters would go to
Bernie so that's 33% of 14
that's roughly like 4 and 2/3 call it 5
so that gets Bernie to 28 and then
you've got 14 plus 32% of 23 which is
like 11 plus 14 is 25 okay yeah I mean
so there you you could make a quick case
see the thing is unless you're really
looking at the specific states and
breaking it down that way more than
likely the Democratic candidate is going
to win the popular vote that's the
reality so you really need to look at
this I think you need to slice and dice
it a little bit more and you know if
only if only we could do the math on it
and then we could we could really figure
it out but that's an interesting idea
okay let's see other messages that came
in Abhinav Sanga Sethi says via YouTube
super chat what's your opinion on Iran
protests against the Islamic Republic
yeah my dad was sending me a bunch of
stuff about that and I will likely talk
about it tomorrow if not Tuesday but
I've been doing a lot of research on
that people asking if Tulsi dropped out
I don't I don't believe that she did let
me say thank you to James Auburn James
Auburn is the fourth new member let's
watch it move there it goes I can move
my entire body instead of just my finger
and then eventually we would be like
over here four of 15 new members the
target is indeed 15 and we will open the
phone lines if we get to that point okay
over on Twitch we are 65% of the way to
hype train level 5 and we have reached
it thanks to CG bang who just gave out
to tier one community sub gifts we have
reached we have reached hype train level
5 oh no we've completed level 4 we've
completed level 4 we are now at hype
train level 5 let's see what the
parameters are completing level 5
requires combine support events totaling
six tier 1 subs or 3000 bits
ok well we'll see if we can make it to
that let's continue here alright I want
to play a video for you I tweeted about
this yesterday by the way if you if you
followed me on Twitter you would have
known about this 24 hours ago this kid
right here has upper management written
all over him I don't know who this girl
is
let's see Kaitlyn Bennet Kent State gun
girl let's look up who this is Kaitlyn
Bennett is an American gun rights
advocate anti-abortion activist and
social media personality she received
media attention for open caring and it
can you imagine getting attention for
carrying a weapon around you should get
police attention
that's the attention you should get
anyway I guess she does these interviews
and she goes and she interviews this guy
and says tampons and men's bathrooms
condoms or something in women's
bathrooms it's basically just anti-trans
you know people who are shocked I don't
know who this is
I don't watch anything i I don't buy I
don't watch any of this crap anyway this
guy is is just like why do you care why
do you care about this stuff who cares
take a listen to this upper management
written all over them about putting
urinals
and women's restrooms for women who have
penises and they just want to stand and
peek I think people just making too big
about it naughty words okay so we should
or shouldn't I mean I really care what
about tampons and pads and men's
restroom for men who have periods if
you're really getting that worked up
about it why doesn't matter like I don't
care just sitting there I'm not gonna
take it we should provide men with
tampons I mean if a dude wants a tampon
for some reason he can have a tampon
that's not my business that's the best
right it's like who cares if a friend of
mine said hey you know what if a male
friend said I'm carrying around tampons
I would say what do they for I don't
care what you do but that's weird what
like what do you need it for and if they
said they'd give me an explanation I'd
say all right well I don't care who
cares what would you use it for
I don't know that's his problem will we
use a pad for his problem do you think
they should seek medical advice if
they're having bleeding I mean if they
want to I don't really care why should I
here I care about people they're leaning
out of their penis I would want to I
care about people's personal rights they
can do whatever they want some none of
my business so this guy's the best
I mean I'm gonna use this let's just
check out I am curious were there any of
any of the other ones went like this so
just let's just take a look what's in
your laptop case your laptop you sure
that's not what I heard
I have an important question for you
what do you think about putting urinals
in the women's restroom for women who
have penises this is the right reaction
who cares let's figure out how to get
people health health care let's take a
listen to this one two yeah there's
there's there's more than people think
what men having periods mhm yeah I got
did you tell them to seek political help
if men are having periods trans men have
periods
okay explain that one to me yeah so as
people who have transitioned from female
to male
you know obviously you know they might
still have periods and you know if they
identify as male you know they have the
right to go into the men's room but if
they're still having periods they have
the right to have you know the products
they need there's there's this this is
just the best I love this let's see it
looks like they're uh did she called
trans women predators let's see Truman
they identify as a woman oh who would
have known men walking into ok don't
question anything about men walking into
women's restrooms ever they're just
there cuz they're women they're not
predator trim then they identify as an
apprentice yeah just imagine carrying so
much
[Laughter]
he's gonna make a good narrative because
he doesn't say a word and she makes no
man what a troll yeah the best thing I
think is ignore her and also just say
who cares about these things it doesn't
make any difference okay so it looks
like we got only two hypetrain level
five and then things fell apart which is
okay it's still higher than than we've
ever gotten before all right let's see
other questions that have come in via
super chat let me see here I didn't okay
Abhinav Stanga said he says what time do
your streams usually start and end there
is no usual usually they don't they
don't start before 6 p.m. Eastern and
they rarely end after 11 p.m. Eastern
but within that it could be any time
Julius Robinson says via super chat I
don't believe in second choice polling
if there's no option to say none what
are your thoughts second choice well I
mean that depends on whether you're
talking to someone who's definitely
voting right if if if someone is
definitely voting it doesn't really
matter if it says none because they're
going to pick someone else so I'd have
to think about that a little more I
don't know that that's necessarily
problematic
although yeah all right let's continue I
want to say thanks to creative name 1000
for signing up with twitch prime as well
as everybody else who has done so let's
keep going ok I already played this for
you all right so let's let's go to
through some voicemails now so I'm gonna
give you a little bit of a peek behind
the curtain one of the things I
typically do on Sunday evening is I go
through the voicemails that came in to
figure out what we might be able to use
on the broadcast show during the week
and it can sometimes get a little bit
ugly so let's just let's just start
listening to them
and see if any of these are usable oh
wait a second here we go that's longer
what do you think about this based on my
own observation I kind of think that the
people who support Trump hate liberals
with a passion because they think all
right I can just tell it's not not good
and I know that a lot of a lot of people
this might seem like I'm being
judgmental but what I'm seeing is I'm
listening to it
I'm seeing a transcript of it and I'm
looking at the duration of it and I'm
also noticing whether it's someone who
calls like 30 times a day so within like
five seconds I can basically tell if
we're going to be using using it or not
David this is safe from California and
you are once again correct Lindsey
Graham said that president Trump's yep I
can tell we're not using it let's take a
listen to another one hi David my name
is Topher I'm from Provo and Orem Utah
area
my dad posted on Facebook today yep not
using it it's three minutes long and if
that's the the cadence it'll take the
full three minutes to get to the point
let's take a listen to another one David
this is Robert and Riverside dude you
are driving me insane with calling her
tulsi gabbard or that's why I do a bard
or whatever you come up with her name is
Tulsi Gabbard I know Tulsi is probably
because she's a Russian tool I didn't
think that dude please stop that's
actually sort of funny so that I'll
download that one and I'll put it in a
possible folder which I'm doing right
now let's see voicemail will call that
angry with Tulsi and okay that's a maybe
we've got a bunch of three-minute
voicemails I'm not even gonna get into
here let's see I David this is Jason
from Portland so I wanted to talk to you
about your I wanted to get feedback on
the universal basic income I've done 100
smells on that topic that's why I know
right away that I'm skipping it
here's another three-minute one which is
no good let's take a listen to another
one I gave it this is Bill from
Minnesota listen not we okay and then he
calls back I gave it this is Bill from
Minnesota I'm sorry about that last call
I got disconnected listen um you know I
agree with everything you say I'm with
you 100% thank god there's still people
out there to think like you and me but
so instead just agreeing with there with
with all the issues that we're out here
and it goes I can I'm skipping ahead
this the transcript it's about ayahuasca
so I don't think that that's I don't
know anything about that the battle
debacle debacle I like that that's like
when William Shatner said sabotage I
like that debacle so I get this is not
usable right so on the last stream I
watched a debate Sam cedar had with a
vegan I can't do a voicemail on my
broadcast show about a debate that
happened on the Sam cedar show that
nobody saw right so that I can
immediately tell you that this one is
this one's no good I think this next one
is from troll caller Troy York a David
Pakman what facts do you have that
President Trump is getting advice from
Tucker Carlson that is just total
fabrication it's a lie I'm kind of bored
with Troy York so I'm just moving on I
that's like a two and a half minute
voicemail and it's not you know a lot of
three-minute ones I'll just give you so
here's like another three minute one
three minutes is the max that's allowed
so when I see three minutes the person
talked all the way up to the beep which
is we've never aired a three-minute
voicemail before but just for kicks I'll
play it just to give you a sense of what
that sounds like
hey David
means J I'm from Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
I big fan - okay I just want to let you
know that I served for 16 years into the
Air Force as a fare rescue man I've been
overseas Iraq matter of fact I ran I'll
be 45 in March I was in Fallujah
actually was blown up and flew have a
titanium plate my April roadside bomb
broke Kevin said blew it out in my left
lage radius and all novels risk my Oprah
bone left side of my face to my nose
secret so I mean it I I feel terribly
for what happened to this gentleman but
so I can tell in reading that it
actually he's giving back story up until
the three minute mark is reached and and
of course unfortunately that's not
usable for a two-minute voicemail
segment let's see what else we have I'm
skipping some because I want to give you
guys like a sense of different things
instead of actually listening to all of
these let's take a listen to another one
hello David I mean first of all a Bernie
supporter and I do believe that he is
very likely to win the presidency but on
the other hand I'm a realist and I think
people are a lot of the supporters are
being very naive if they're not
expecting some sort of capitulation and
Anna Sanders a presidency and I want to
there's an article in the most recent in
these Times magazine dirt and Brian
Brian tocar called why Bernie can't be
organizer in chief so my question is do
you think that a lot of these are Bernie
supporters especially a lot of the
social media in this and a lot of these
people do YouTube channels are bracing
themselves for a disappointment if
they're not expecting some sort of
concessions so I kind of I've addressed
that before and I can't think of any
other way to do it that won't just piss
a lot of people off so I don't I don't
know that it's a good a good one here is
Troy York calling back with another one
of his fake names this time it's woody
Underwood he does this like all night
David Pakman this is woody Underwood hey
I think that you're dumber think Backman
is dumber than take Tolbert
I think basically you're mentally
declining your car
the Clyde is going down the net your
early age twenty-something because you
cannot even tell anyway so then he
called back again and so this is it
these are all Troy York he called
earlier with no name then he called his
woody Underwood he immediately called
back sixteen minutes later this time he
claims his name is like it's like Dave
Burke's in or something
hey David this is Dave Burke see just
calling a couple of points that you
brought up the today's program again you
just keep stating at China not paying
the tariffs well whether you believe it
or not and you're gonna keep mentioning
it outside but China is paying for
tariffs just from the fact that they're
not meeting the projected growth that
the business protectionist and yes the
projectionists who project films they
are projectionists for films as well as
for economics apparently okay I'm
skipping over a couple from people that
I've already played for you who are
calling multiple times and I don't I
don't want to deal with that but as you
can see so the point is we've already
gone through about thirty including the
ones I have played for you and the ones
I haven't played for you and we have one
maybe so far so it really is very very
slim pickins let's take a look at let's
take a look at one other hi David this
is Matthew from Kansas I enjoyed hearing
your thoughts on some of the best
Argentine rock bands and I just wanted
to plug put in a plug for my own
favorite which is an amazing band from
the 70s called Suey Jenna T I'm sure
you've heard of them oh yeah but anybody
out there who might want to just have
their mind blown go ahead and check them
out Swede unity thanks a lot David yep
very nice message not useful for the
broadcast show of course let's see a lot
of repeat calls so like this person
keeps calling for example hey David this
is Dave in California there was a
Republican congressman called Collins he
went on TV on
and so again this is three minutes long
and it's not a story we've done so
anyway there's more but I think that
this gives you guys kind of a sense of
what we're picking from every every week
so we we sort of do the best we can
right I mean that's that's that's really
all we can do I see a lot of people
including valve from Agawam asking if
the phone lines are going to open and I
I don't know Val because we've our
target is 15 new members we're at four
and that's with an extraordinary coupon
code right so the if you go to my
website join pakman.com i yearly because
you save even more money you type in the
coupon code 2020 now and it drops it to
twenty dollars and 20 cents which is of
course the year that we're in and you
don't even have to do it yearly if you
want to do it monthly it's more
expensive over the course of a year but
you can use the same coupon code and
it'll drop it to two dollars and two
cents if 11 more people sign up and then
the bar will fill up completely and
explode off of the screen I will I will
I will open up the phone lines now I am
seeing maybe I should even add something
let me know if this if this would would
yeah this is this this is because it's
uh this fixes itself if I didn't have my
browser yeah anyway let's let's get off
that I don't know if people would be
interested in this but I see a lot of
people in the chat mentioning that a
couple streams ago I demonstrated just
the the firm pliability of my hair by
puffing it all up like in my profile
picture on Twitter and people are asking
for me to do that again if we get to 20
new members I will do that and just as a
little preview just look at just just
one push and it starts to get very crazy
so that that's something that we can
maybe stick on the tail end if things go
really well with new memberships okay
let me answer a few other super chats
that are coming in super chats of course
the best way to get a question in front
of me which I will read and react to a
DD says hey David do you know if the
spider tailed Viper I know nothing about
it I know nothing about
Courtney Haynes says David thanks for
never buying into the economic anxiety
narrative numerous studies have shown
exactly why Trump has voted the way they
did yeah so here's the thing there is
there there is an economic anxiety
component but it's basically of people
that don't look like you achieving equal
status and when you're used to a
privileged status equality seems like
discrimination so in in that very narrow
sense defined in exactly that way we you
could say that you you could that
economic anxiety is accurate but it's
accurate in a very very narrow sense
let's see people are asking where is the
link for membership it is just join
pakman.com join pakman.com very very
simple website and that's of course PA
que ma n all right so we did this let's
move on to I haven't seen this yet and I
wanted to watch it with you guys I've
been I've been reading that Donald Trump
we covered this rally last week and I
didn't see this part Donald Trump
apparently says he should win the Nobel
Prize because he saved Ethiopia I have
no clue what he said but let's take a
look at Salamone was actively planning
new attacks on Ted he was looking very
seriously at our embassies and not just
the embassy in Baghdad but we stopped
him and we stopped him quickly and we
stopped him cold
so in my direction the United States
military eliminated Qasem Soleimani and
ended his rampage through not only that
part of the world but much bigger parts
of the world he was all over he was a
parts of the world Trump could not find
out about bad guy he was a bloodthirsty
terror and he's no Terra I like that
longer a Terran he's dead
I mean I'm gonna tell you about the
Nobel Peace Prize I'll tell you about
that yeah I made a deal I saved a
country and I just heard that the head
of that country is now getting the Nobel
Peace Prize for saving the country I
said what did I have something to do
with it yeah but you know that's the way
it is as long as we know that's all that
matters okay no one in the audience
knows what he said there's no one in the
audience could possibly know what it is
that he is talking about I mean that
just makes absolutely no sense
whatsoever
wow that is weird let me say thanks to
Ian Fitzpatrick for signing up at join
pakman.com as well as matthew ellis that
gets us to six six new members very much
appreciate your support okay let me know
okay so for people asking where to call
to leave voicemails the normal voicemail
number that we were just checking out is
two one nine two david p two one nine
two david p if you want the the other
voicemail number that's a funny one is
the live calls number which is six one
seven eight three zero 4750 and
sometimes people call that when we're
not actually taking live calls and those
voicemails can be pretty funny and i
actually want to listen to a couple of
them with you right now let's see what
what's been going on there
okay that's just a hang-up okay well if
they're saying don't use this on the
show I will stop it but I couldn't hear
a word of it anyway so no risk of that
David this is Colonel Carey Maxwell
calling from Santa Cruz California and
I'm a smart person and I'm in a smart
wing and I will tell you the Democrats
will lose if they do not it
[Music]
from being for open state sanctuary
cities and sanctuary states if they do
not defend us from the immigration
invasion they will lose I'm simpatico to
immigrants but I don't want a billion
more people try to live here than we can
accommodate a billion huh okay I didn't
know that that was happening let's take
a listen to a couple others okay that
was weird almost sounded like my voice
in the background a lot of hang-ups
happening hi David Pakman this is
Aristotle from Modesto California and I
just wanted your opinion on this I think
I'm I left a call for you about a few
weeks ago I don't know you got to it
because that any probably got a ton of
calls going through but uh my initial
question for you is I know we got a lot
of [ __ ] going on with Iran right now and
the whole Soleimani assassination and
that's all absolutely all I'm hearing
about right now and I'm kind of curious
to see or to see what your opinion is on
if if are we officially at war with Iran
now no no we're not okay that's a quick
one I can answer that and move right on
i mr pac-man oh oh here we go
is this the same hillbilly is this so
here's the question is that guy where is
it is are we listening to the same
person here yeah David you know you
think that it's too damn bad living in
the United States what I can't tell if
it's the same guy let's see what is that
with all the hate mongering on you
[ __ ] Facebook threads oh no this guy
sounds like he's on my side this is a
how can you say this [ __ ] and not wanna
go say hey y'all can [ __ ] pay like
this it's [ __ ] ridiculous what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you people
you want to make fun of people like that
[ __ ] April just cuz they won't secure
borders and then look at yo oh no this
guy is against me okay it's like you
can't even he's just ranting you can't
even tell if he's in favor of what I'm
saying or against it yours hateful
ignorant as can be please answer your
phone so I can tell you how [ __ ]
stupid you are we can debate I will be
respectful answer your phone what is it
[ __ ] wrongly uh answer when it's from an
area code that's [ __ ] Democrat
majority no it's that you called at 6:15
in the morning on a Saturday and that's
not when I livestream what the [ __ ] are
you lazy and only answer it two or three
times a day through these things a day
two three times a week my friends you
don't nothing but hate monger in LA on
[ __ ] Facebook and it's pathetic the
answer your phone so we can talk and cut
uh we can come to a conclusion on
whether or not your hate mongering it's
really sad what's happened to Lindsey
Graham actually let me I am going to
save that one because that might have
some mileage I don't even know what to
call it
loud hate monger dude needs bleeping if
we are going to use it on the broadcast
show though that is for that is for sure
let me invite you to re-up or start a
twitch Prime subscription if you're
watching on twitch if you have Amazon
Prime you can subscribe for free on
Twitch Prime and that supports us and it
costs you absolutely nothing let me say
hi to a couple of other new members here
I don't want to ignore anybody Jonathan
Hughes has just signed up for a David
Pakman show
membership Richard prude NCO is a new
David Pakman show member Chris the
Brittany David Pakman show member as is
Cody Hinshaw thanks Cody and Margaret
Western that's five more which gets us
to eleven if we set actually let me see
if I can do this let me see if this
works
did that work no that didn't work let's
see here fifty new members huh there's
some way I can put up a second goal here
yeah there we go okay so there we go
okay good so now I'll do phone brilliant
okay good all right so if we get to
fifteen new members we will open up the
phone lines and then if we get to twenty
I will you know do the do the crazy hair
thing and there will be memes and it'll
all be it'll it'll be a huge thing ok
very good margaret western we thanked
and now let's get over to super chats
dave rubin in the chat dave rubin says
how much would i have to donate for you
to try to convince ven shapiro to come
to my university party um i don't know
five hundred bucks
pyro plasma says are you pro gun
confiscation or just more control so
listen i have no problem whatsoever with
the concept of quote confiscating guns
which is not the language i use what
anguish i would use is as a society we
decide we are going to make ourselves
safer by taking certain weapons that
serve no purpose other than to
facilitate mass killing off the streets
you might call it a confiscation i call
it that i just think that it doesn't we
are so far from even doing much easier
things to do and there is such low
hanging fruit that i would not start
with trying to confiscate any firearms I
would start with universal background
checks eliminating the gun show loophole
restricting and
making ammunition more expensive
requiring gun insurance requiring
relicensing etc etc etc let's see other
super chats that have come in Shiv
Saxena says what do you think about
private property how about intellectual
property do you mean private property in
the way that a Marxist would use it or
just the idea of people owning stuff
like computers need to clarify that as
far as intellectual property I think
that you I am not against copyright
trademark etc on principle I think we
need to be more thoughtful about how we
do it in order to encourage and
discourage the right behaviors so to
speak and to prevent rent-seeking that
is bad for the the economy at large
Nova Ceaser says I left you a voicemail
about right to work from Indiana
alright well I may hear it at some point
alright that's that let me thank a few
new twitch prime subscribers the big
loon says thanks for everything love the
show seen your beefs subscribed with
twitch prime Marv one two three six
subscribed with twitch prime D g3 241
subscribed with twitch prime & gert 156
has also subscribed with with twitch
prime thank you so much I appreciate
that
alright I'm I need your help finding
something that I wanted to do on stream
today and I don't know exactly where to
find it which is there were some
interviews that I saw that we're done
with Trump supporters outside the most
recent rally the read the rally in Ohio
including with a young kid who was asked
what's one thing Trump did that you like
and and the kid couldn't name anything
can someone tell me how to find those
find those interviews because I'm
interested in in playing some of those
and I just don't know where to find them
Trump supporter rally I'm searching
Twitter Trump supporter rally interview
they're all from to 2019 so that's not
it
from supporter Oh
iö maybe oh I found one of them actually
is it but it's a Vic Vic burger video
and sometimes he modifies them I think I
found some of them though let's take a
look
I'll see you believe the president has
done well
i I I just I'm not really sure is
I just support him look is that doctored
I can't tell I can't tell if that's dr.
let's see something else here get out of
the way of the folks coming up here
what's your name okay
say that again okay beau gray what are
you doing out here [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
this is child abuse right can I even
play this I don't even know if I can
play this you just reminded me of my
daughter when you said that your naina
and Popeye god bless you lord I just
pray a special blessing you tell me
you'd both is it Bo I pray a special
blessing on bowl or wasn't the names
kids kids named graves but I pray that
you would bless and keep him you'd make
it your face to shine upon him be
gracious unto him raise him up Lord into
the warrior that you having to be let
this light shine out of this young man
lord I pray in any of the darkness that
wants to how how come Lord that your
light would just shine through it man
I'm glad to meet you Bo and I'm glad
that your papa and that is it nana neyni
nana your pop on your name they brought
you out here
[Music]
I'm eight years old I go to school and
volumen Elementary that is so cool and
did you get to get out of school today
to come see the president yes is this
your mom that didn't hurt your feelings
[Music]
this your first time to see him how
excited are you on a scale of one to ten
you know dude do you realize what what
people in Canada think when they see
this
I mean I know that Trump is don't care
but do you understand Europe do you
understand what people are what's
happening over there people are asking
us what how how I feel bad for this kid
[Music]
so when he comes out on that stage are
you just gonna be going crazy
anything else you want to see did you
play football I see the football shirt
[Music]
don't play football
maybe it's such an honor to meet you
young man and shout out to your mom god
bless ya all right that's great that's
goodness oh my goodness
so this one we already saw this one we
already saw yeah and then we get to just
2019 stuff so Wow I mean that is that is
something else right that is extremely
depressing extremely depressing okay I
see the super chats and the and the
twitch prime subs let me just welcome
Eric Driggers as well as jet JL JL
Martin appreciate your support that gets
us to 13 members for the evening thank
you very very much
okay a pyro plasma says would you take
away those guns from cops as wells at
cops as well III think that it's okay
for police to be armed although the
question is with what right and I think
that that's a different conversation
stand up and fight back says stand up
and fight back okay Sam here says raise
the age limit to 25 for weapons that's
an idea that's been floated around
Alexander stone says could you interview
bow of the fifth column I will joy will
look into it
I will look into it always interested in
interview suggestions Ben Dover says in
high school I could tell the powers of
the president were pretty extensive and
things could go south south fast if
there was a bad apple should we really
be upset Trump exposes the true dangers
of these powers I've said this almost
word-for-word last week Ben if that's
your real name
Brennan Classen says hey thanks David
what platform do you play chess on I
play on chess commonly chess thank you
for the opportunity I meant to tell you
guys next Tuesday February 21st is the
first annual David Pakman show chess
tournament Onley chess org anybody can
enter 8:00 p.m. Eastern Time Tuesday the
21st I will be playing in it may be
staff will be playing in it I don't know
so if you play chess regularly if you
don't it's open to everybody register on
Leach s org and I will go live I will
play live the entire tournament it'll
just be an hour tournament three minute
games it'll be three plus two games
three you start with three minutes you
get two seconds per move additional and
you just get points for each game and we
will have a we will have some winner at
the end I'm not that good
I've only played against destiny once I
didn't beat him it was a thirty second
game and I was I was not prepared for it
and I did not beat him I don't play
thirty-second chess either so I don't
really know the strategy so this is open
to anybody there is no way I'm going to
win there are some really good players
in our audience
so the chess david pakman show chess
tournament will be Tuesday the 21st at
8:00 p.m. Eastern not this Tuesday this
Tuesday I'll be live streaming the
debate maybe unless I get shut down
which I probably will next Tuesday at 8
p.m. it'll be on Lee chess org and you
will be able to find the tournament when
we go live at david pakman.com slash
chess so make a note of it in your
calendar please I would love to have
like at least 50 people play in the
tournament which would be cool okay
let's see other Super chats Jane
womanpower I feel you David from Canada
sick indoctrination of children yeah
that this video was ugly foolishness
says hey David I'm from France and don't
you think resources and climate problems
are bigger threats to us than the rise
of right-wing ideology they go hand in
hand and the rise of right-wing ideology
prevents us from fixing a lot of
problems so I would I would be I would
hesitate to rank that those issues in
that exact way tome you bone says is
there a list of everything every
horrible thing Trump has done of
everything every horrible thing Trump
has done had a cohort co worker today
tell me he likes him because he's
unproblematic yeah that's an uninformed
person you can't do much about that
unfortunately King's hound says hey
David jankura is running for congress
when will you know plans do you think he
has a chance yes I do
I don't know anything about the polling
but my instinct is that Genk has a
chance based on his fundraising Ostend
rice is a new david pakman show member
and his new member number 14 of the
evening 14 of the evening thank you so
much let me get the twitch thank-yous in
just an Avery Smith subscribed with
twitch prime ugly Buddha subscribed with
twitch prime and backdoor also
subscribed with twitch prime folks
asking about it being really warm in
Boston today yeah I mean listen so it
was over 70 degrees in Boston today it's
January okay it should be like a high of
28 so I loved it in the sense that you
know is it's not really pleasant to walk
around when it's 28 it's much more
pleasant when it's 71 but something is
very clearly wrong is my instinct and
it's concerning and it's scary and I
think we're in trouble
thanks to Mia max 231 for the five
dollar super chat a lot of demands for
vegan stuff in the chat I'm not going to
do any vegan stuff today or maybe even
any other day it's it's not a big topic
for my show and it leads to a lot of
people getting really angry and it's
just it's just not you know we've got
other topics that are central to my show
dusty Dark Horse says rest in peace rush
drummer Neil Peart or Neil Peart as some
pronounce it it's very very sad very sad
I did not actually know that Neil was
sick he isn't rush is a absolutely
fantastic band and was very sad to hear
the news and a lot of a lot of people I
am friends with on Facebook who are not
drummers had posted things and
extremely sad I mean what else what else
can you say no I'm not vegan for people
wondering what I mean but I'm not by I'm
not doing vegan stuff on the show I'm
not vegan but what I mean is I'm not
doing like debates with vegans or
whatever there's lots of shows that do
that and we don't we just don't really
do it on the show no it's not it's not a
big deal okay
I think we are about to open the phone
lines because I think we are getting new
member number 15 actually no we're not
no we're not but listen it seems we're
we may be opening the phone line soon so
I'm gonna assume that we are going to
get one more member at join pakman.com
and that we are going to open those
phone lines just as a quick reminder the
the coupon code of the day is 2020 now
at $60 I love it
at 20 dollars and 20 cents it's a
must-have and that's what it becomes
with the coupon code 2020 now and we
will we will get those phone lines
opened if that indeed is the case Pro
thing says have you bread about the
protests in tehran at the david pakman
misspelled show i've read about the
protests in tehran and i'm going to talk
about them tomorrow that it is very
interesting what's going on there
anomaly or anomaly both pronunciations
are valid Trump is the Antichrist and my
boobs poop blood that's odd
that's odd and I would definitely seek
medical attention there for sure is that
that sounds a problematic did I say
tyranny I meant to say Tehran
I might have missed Bernie I might have
gotten so confused by that voice meant
by that a super chat that I did I said
it wrong Tehran
so I also hear some people say Tehran
but I don't I don't know that that's
correct
Tehran yeah that's the right
pronunciation interviews people asking
about interviews this week on the show
we have some good interviews coming up I
will be interviewing oh so there's this
NYU professor Roy German
who recently had some videos go viral
where he hangs out with Hasidic Jews and
they're actually pretty interesting and
I invited him on and he's going to be on
this week let's just take a look at a
little bit of what Roy Germano has been
doing and then I have a really great
guest announcement for you let's see
here just kind of endearing interesting
videos
[Music]
this is in Brooklyn by the way in Crown
Heights I believe everybody knows him
because he's been doing videos with a
rabbi in the community and everybody
seems to like him okay anyway so I'll be
interviewing Roy German Oh on the show
and the next week I will be interviewing
the wolf of Wall Street
Jordan Belfort the wolf of Wall Street
Jordan Belfort will be on the program
next week assuming it doesn't get
rescheduled the name of his channel is
Roy German oh he only has 49 hundred
subscribers incredibly but he's gotten a
couple videos that have gone viral so
next week I will be interviewing Jordan
Belfort the wolf of Wall Street send in
questions if you have questions for
Jordan and that will be super
interesting okay if you are just joining
us and you are not currently a
subscriber to the show on YouTube please
hit the subscribe button we're only
twenty-one subscribers from 793 some
thousand so please hit the subscribe
button if you're watching on youtube
please follow if you are watching over
on Twitch we're approaching 23,000
followers there and we are going to get
to the phones
Jill D Meyers has signed up and Bryan
Hanks has signed up which gets us to 16
members if we get to 20 I will do the
stupid hair thing that some people want
me to do so let's get let's get the
phone lines going the phone number is
six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty six one seven eight three
zero 47 50 I'm going to get connected
and dialed in right now and then we will
take a few phone calls and hear from
some people see what's on people's minds
thank you for calling in to the David
Pakman show
please do not use to beat your phone
have your question ready and listen for
David to call out also thanks to Michael
ax McAlister Michael a McAlister
appreciate your support as well that
gets us to 17 only three more and we
will get to the the other goal of 20 all
right
6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 is the number I will
continue to give priority to super chats
and messages with prime memberships
let's start with the 7 5 7 area code
who's calling today from 757 hey I just
want to get some props to you show I've
been watching for a very long time since
the gamer gate scandal years and years
ago and it takes a lot of work to put on
like a presentation like this and keep
it up for so long you've done a great
job with that thank you and one question
I have for you is do you see the
Democrats winning and keeping their
positions that they have right now in
the Congress in the House and Senate and
you see them getting the president
viewed alone okay so if you're saying
what would I bet on today
I bet that Democrats extend the lead in
the house pick up a couple of seats but
don't take the Senate and that Donald
Trump wins the presidency now I know
that when I say this people will get
angry at me and say I'm being defeatist
no I'm not I'm not being defeatist what
I'm saying is if you said today January
12 put money on it that's what I put
money on but I don't actually bet so
instead what I do is I just work to try
to get the outcome I want if that makes
sense but that if you if that's what
it's that that's my sense of what I
would put money on today although I
don't those are not that my desired
outcomes
hello okay gotcha gotcha all right very
good appreciate the phone call thank you
so much looks like we have some kind of
a strange delay going on let's go next
to our caller from the six one seven
area code possible local caller here in
the Boston area
hey David this is Andrew calling from
Jamaica Plain Boston how are you how are
you good good nice finally a chance
thank you in person so this question has
been on my mind actually since November
as you know Kentucky gained a Democratic
governor and Louisiana kept the
Democratic governor yet to reliably read
States and last year as you know
Massachusetts and Vermont kept their
Republican governors which are obviously
too reliably blue states and
interestingly enough in fact I'm pretty
sure that Charlie Baker had a wider gap
than J Gonzales the Democratic
challenger yes Warren had to her
senator challenger deal so my question
is why do blue states like Massachusetts
and Vermont tend to elect Republican
governors while red states like Kentucky
and Louisiana have a track record of
electing Democratic governors I can
speak less to the the southern states
you mentioned that some I don't actually
know the history of how frequently they
elect Democratic governors the here in
Massachusetts we've had a number of
prominent Republican governors we have
Charlie Baker now we had Mitt Romney
William weld we had there there are
others whose names escape me
there's a couple different explanations
one explanation that I've been told is
that the Massachusetts voter is uber
pragmatic and believes that a very left
legislature but a Republican governor is
a great way to make sure that nothing
gets too out of control but that big
picture things keep moving left it seems
it's attributing a lot of agency to
something that may not actually be
deserving of it I think a more likely
explanation is that when you get because
it is such a blue state you often have
low voter turnout
because people just assume in a lot of
these special elections and
gubernatorial ones that the Democrats
going to win and so when you get a smart
and proactive Republican that actually
runs a good campaign before you know it
Democrats who think there's that they
have no shot are way behind and they
can't catch up
III don't know I mean there's a lot of
different explanations for it's probably
different in every state yeah yeah and
if alas were like Louisiana I was
looking at it and besides like Bobby
Jindal if you look at it they've had
they had like four previous Democratic
governors so I just found that
interesting and I yeah so I just thought
I'd yet see what if you had a
perspective on it but it's a very
interesting situation yeah I appreciate
your call great to hear from you thank
you so much let me say welcome to
Brennan Classen Bette Brennan Classen is
today's 18th member also if I pronounce
Michael incorrectly if it's Michaela I
sincerely apologize I couldn't apologize
more sincerely never mean to get
anybody's name wrong but I do appreciate
your support over on YouTube via super
chat Joan Ignasi 91 says should the
United States even ban political TV ads
or limit the time candidates can start
running their campaign to limit the
massive campaign costs as many EU
countries absolutely it's part of the
campaign finance reform ideas that I've
presented many a time let me say thanks
to the chome R for subscribing with
twitch prime overrun twitch thank you so
much I appreciate that let's go next to
our caller from the five six three area
code we are taking callers at six one
seven eight three zero forty seven fifty
caller from five six three go ahead hi
David this is our I I and I was
wondering if you could either interview
or do a show on certainly more
information I'm Nina Turner and also
like to apologize for harassing you
about your here okay thank you very much
I will take both under consideration
thank you all right very good
let me say welcome to Joseph Collins as
well as Joshua Martinez new members
number 19 and 20 of the evening okay all
right so we're doing we're doing the
hair thing look I don't even know if
it'll happen let's just see here it just
it's it's very unpredictable but this is
now people think I'm having an issue
that I'm disheveled and things are crazy
have to go in the right direction here
it's actually not working that well is
it let me see here yeah there we go okay
it's building up now I just want to get
it off the top of the screen it actually
looks like I have a skunk on my head now
this is getting a little crazy let me
see this might be all we can do today
there we go I mean that's something
right like that that's that this is not
and this is not not nothing it is weird
that it's not like it's just not
happening as much I think it might be
something about the warm unusually warm
day in Boston okay let's leave it like
that very good next caller from the 6-5
zero area code caller from six five zero
hi David it's Julie in California hey
Julie I think that your hair has more
admirers than Trump had in his
inauguration it may be I wanted to just
say I want to say what is your opinion
on the Goldwater rule and how is it if
you think it's affecting what's going on
right now I I actually don't know that
it is affecting what's going on right
now and what's your sense of it you know
I read up on it and I thought you know I
really thought that it was kind of kind
of like old what's the old hat but it
just kind of seemed like it's not really
taking effect but I to be quite honest I
agree with what you're saying that I
think there's a very good chance
unfortunately that he's going to get in
again and what troubles me though is
that when if it's if it's if he doesn't
get in like let's say you know he
somehow you know everything go something
happens and he does not get elected I'm
really worried that
his supporters are gonna just you know
it's going to be really scary there's
gonna be a lot of upheaval and a lot of
violence and I could be very long on
that because I kind of I do feel however
if we press him I feel like you'd like a
trapped animal like a cornered animal
you know I agree and did I hope I hope
that you're wrong but I fear that you're
right but for people who don't know the
Goldwater rule the Goldwater rule is
this idea the psychiatric idea that you
should not evaluate someone or diagnose
someone that you have not examined in
person and we've interviewed
psychiatrists who say that was developed
for a very specific reason at a very
specific time there there is so much
material of Donald Trump that mental
health professionals can reasonably make
assessments about at least what might be
going on with him and that the Goldwater
rule is often cited reflexively by
people who don't really understand it
merely to say everything's fine with
Trump and clearly not everything is fine
as it sounds like you're pointing out
right exactly okay well thank you very
much all right thank you I appreciate
the call so nice to hear from you
Jane womanpower sent a super chat that
says number one disheveled hair
number two komen tease number three
hairspray from a part of Canada where
your hair is too tame and not from
Quebec okay well it seems like a lot of
things are going on there
Abhinav Sanga Sethi says how do you call
in six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty is the number
thanks to Jessica Lara for subscribing
with twitch prime thanks to Zach six six
six Soros who says Bernie can win and
thanks to Daniel 84 six months
subscribed at Tier one
I very much appreciate that thank you so
much let's go next to our caller from
the five one seven area code who's
calling today from five one seven
it's Michaela I think you pronounced it
that also I eventually got it Michaela
not Michael and Michaela you did it's
cool um all right I called her about my
yeah we recently had Ellen why pass
right to work and I was one
that you think that'll affect me other
states nearby or which is the one off
will it affect it in terms of the labor
market or a little effect that in terms
of the kind of contagion and getting
other states to vote for it as well I
was thinking more like contagion like I
might want to start to do that but I
don't have to be like a one-off or not
no III have not seen evidence that
right-to-work spreads in that way it
seems like certain activists target
certain states based I don't think it's
based on geography it's based more on
politics so I don't think I mean there
may be contagion but it would be
political contagion not Geographic okay
thank you all right thank you very much
appreciate the phone call let's go next
to our caller from I guess it's country
code 86 is that was that right yes it is
hello yes you're gonna you're gonna want
to turn me down in the background there
oh yeah yeah you're turned down I
apologize that the pause and I'm
watching a lot who's this cool job from
time oh yeah yeah yeah you've called the
broadcast show before yeah yeah I'm it's
been hard to get a hold of you lately
because you switch the twitch and
everything but hey I'm here man I know
you got a limited amount of time first
of all I wanted to say that [ __ ]
what I'm getting my bad no you're doing
swear this isn't rod Castro so you can
swear today yeah
Oh word okay cool that [ __ ] between
you and that rational national Calculon
see calculus key it was it was nonsense
it was own no idea what you're talking
about
what I don't want rational national oh
no no no no I apologize I thought you
had like a bit of beef with calculus key
and rational national taking your word
like your your commentary about dang I'm
throwing a blame well whatever it is I
if that's the climate may be irate but I
haven't seen anything I don't know what
you're talking about oh oh never mind
I'm gonna skip that up nothing
personally I just want to say that yeah
you you always come with a very rational
take on everything that you present to
you I mean to the audience and to
people abroad I've never listened to
anything that you said and thought oh
he's taking a cowardly way out oh my god
or Singh Bernie you're a commentator
like you you yeah and I you get straight
to the point but besides that I want to
get to why I think that Bernie Sanders
if he really wants to win if he really
wants to solidify the african-american
vote in the states he needs to focus on
things like Flint the water crisis in
Flint I've heard very little come out of
most of the Democratic candidates mouths
about how to solve it what they will do
to fix that our children are being
poisoned our kids will have lifelong
effects and also poor whites poor whites
live there if you want to solidify the
working man's the working man's vote
talk about that this place is in
Louisiana who are suffering from a water
crisis poison water due to fracking
places in our Florida who are facing
water crisis crises and the guy really
wished that more and more of the top top
Democratic candidates like Bernie
Sanders visible war and [ __ ] even I even
injury aim speak about it talk about
people are being affected by it if you
want those votes talk about that hey I
would definitely vote for the first
third and say day one I will fix Flint I
would send the army of course the
engineers to fix it I like it I think
you're making a very good guy and if you
are if listen if the idea is that
Democrats are not properly appealing to
rural and Midwestern so called flyover
States which is a pejorative term but I
think everybody knows what I'm talking
about
let's find some ways to get through it
that aligned with our values yes yes in
the value is you don't want your kids to
be mentally disabled for the rest of
their lives or you want your government
if they see that issue to take care of
it to promise those children right we
will be taking two primers those
families
you will be taking care of hey listen
like they what's mean what's yet what's
going on in China these days what are
the how is your proficiency in Mandarin
and like what's going on well my
proficiency is uh is pretty low I I can
get around I feel I mean living here for
a while I'm gonna I'm gonna focus on
what you asked but living here for a
while I definitely sympathize with any
migrant worker anybody of of
first-generation that come to America
and struggle with learning English my
I've already had sympathy but it grew
further living here in China but what's
going on in China mainland I live in r1
and mainland China they get the news
they ask me questions when I'm in the
taxi I asked as best as possible they
know about Iran they know about was with
yet like the taxi drivers are very
political hearing one they will ask you
a question in a heartbeat like hey what
yeah um my friend of mine I wish I can
get my friend my friend Brian was here
he's uh profession very proficient in
Chinese he can tell you all kinds of
things that they talk about and once a
chain manager end up spoken yes Mandarin
I'm speaking Mandarin Hong Kong they're
the ones that normally just because
Cantonese right and like I don't want to
but I just have I know the last time you
called it was super interesting you
mentioned if I recall last time that
you're a black American man is that are
there many in China that or is that also
something that attracts attention when
you're walking around I could tension
because they have very little contact
with people of color however is not
negative attention like you know get out
of here you know but they they're very
curious people very nice like um it's
like any innocent ignorance and I would
put it that way they they're just
curious and there's plenty of natural
natural men here and the Wuhan
especially if it's an education hub
interesting I've meet people for yeah
I mean people from all over the world
here I love this city because I talked
about I have a close friend who Syrian
who like to discuss the conflict that's
going on his country I have a friend
from Zambia have a dating a girl from
Seychelles
I like really that's interesting so so
it's you wouldn't likely be get into a
dating situation with with somebody who
only speaks Mandarin I'm guessing since
that that would be effectively
impossible actually I was in a
relationship with a woman who spoke
mostly Mandarin and uh it wasn't
impossible but I learned a lot of
Chinese Mandarin Wow
in the relationship it's all good that
you're going the food the cuisine oh I
love Chinese food here right me and my
bad I love the local food here I
apologize like yeah this is for the
audience but it's completely different
from what we get in the States normally
like PF Changs and guy said only one I
tell you that much I would assume not I
would have saw my guy yeah yeah we're
getting garbage in the States
well we already know that but I would
wish that uh we can get more authentic
Chinese cuisine back home rugged man rug
on me and if anybody is listening tell
David Pakman about it I'm trying to tell
him now hey where you livin good many
did you sell what was that you said
rugged men oh and apologize for my
pronunciation I have no I apologize
really brag on me in rude on me okay
like it's a translates to hot dry
noodles it's one of the one of the most
celebrated cuisines in one everyone
loves it you know it is a pretty much
noodles saturated in sesame sesame seed
or sesame seed sauce okay and they add
like herbs and spices it's delicious if
you get a chance to try it if your
noodle guy suggested
fascinating my last Chinese food
experience was in the Hasidic London out
suburb of Hendon on Christmas Day one
the few places where I was able to get a
reservation with some friends and I
don't recommend kosher Chinese food let
me put that right out on the table I
mean that sounds that sounds terrible
you know that sounds absolutely horrible
like yo you got to get that nitty-gritty
Chinese food where they don't wash their
hands and they just squat determinate
and everything that's how you know it's
authentic sure sure no yeah look for
sure okay okay very good
yeah I hope to hear from you again yeah
if you have any more questions I hope to
be able to call and have another convo
man thank you again and I'll be you know
watching absolutely and stop change my
number so that it'll come up properly on
caller ID okay oh oh I didn't came to
you yeah that's weird
very strange right well we'll call we we
will call someone in security services
over there and I'm sure they will get it
all straightened up okay cool cool thank
you all right go drop great to hear from
cool cool drops a good guy I always
always love to hear love to hear from
cool drop alright it's gotten late and
I've got to go to bed because we've got
a whole new show tomorrow thanks to
everybody who joined me we will have
next stream pre-debate stream on YouTube
Tuesday night then debate stream over on
Twitch follow follow subscribe all these
different things and and you know don't
know no anti semitic messages in